well um as you can see um since we
recorded this dock in my intro we've had
a shelter-in-place order
uh come through the bay area and so
we'll be doing the
questions from each of our homes i'd
like to welcome uh
james nestor thanks for having me hey
hey thanks for being here and um and we
also have uh
dr kevin boyd a chicago chicago
pediatric dentist and a sleep medicine
consultant
uh as well as an assistant professor of
anthropology which i think is such a
great
combo for what you're working on uh at
the university of arkansas i'd love to
welcome in
him into the stream too because i know
we're going to have a lot of um
medical questions so glad kevin dr boyd
i'm here i'm
glad to be here
all right well and i'd love to how did
you end up being both a
pediatric dentist sleep medicine
consultant and a anthropologist
really sick drilling teeth and
uh you know tooth decay is 100
preventable and
didn't want to make a living you know
putting out sugar fires uh and
got curious in the origins of tooth
decay
which led me to the origins of uh
malocclusion you know crooked teeth and
james did a beautiful job
of describing how that happened and they
didn't teach us that in dental school so
i had to go back and almost get a
bachelor's in anthropology
and then it led to uh mentoring phd
research and anthropology and dental
anthropologists
so that's all just curiosity and anger
that my own education that's great
and james do you want to say a little
bit about how you found the researchers
uh like uh like kevin here for sure i
thought i had the whole
breathing field pretty well worked out
uh in non-fiction what you do is you
write a proposal
and i spent about six months writing a
proposal had all the chapters had all
the researchers
and it wasn't until i got much deeper
into this research that
i was missing a huge piece of the puzzle
which is why are we breathing
so poorly it's not just anxiety it's not
just
from the environment from pollution from
allergens it's an anatomical problem
and once i discovered that everything
really opened up in a whole
very weird new way as you saw from some
of that research in the talk
cool and i mean i'm really curious i
mean it seems like 90
of the things that you that you kind of
discovered here have happened in the
last 100 to 200 years
of it's not it's not really human
evolution at that
at that kind of rate it's just um it's
just some
deformations and so do you think in a
few generations or
you know five to ten generations we
could we could get back to our
our straight teeth you know large
airways
well the human body is malleable you
know just as we've
we've injured it uh we we can get it
back certainly
i think it's going to take a while i
think that these these things can come
on very quickly but to
help repair them might take a while i
think that we really need to change
how we're eating food uh other
environmental inputs our oral posture
and so many other things that that
really are contributing to
not only crooked teeth not only poor
breathing
but look at all the other diseases of
civilization out there
you know the top killers in the world
weren't really around
[Music]
uh the huge numbers 200 years ago if
you're looking at diabetes
if if you're looking at uh heart disease
so many other issues
right and i'm curious um
kevin how how widely accepted is this
into
the the dentistry world and orthodontics
and and medical world where
where do we stand in uh how this is
penetrated
into the field well like like anything
you know i was trained to drill phil and
bill and
orthodontists are trained to you know um
straighten crooked teeth and teenagers
and they're making
i was making a great living at just
meeting the public demand and
an orthodontist you know the ex the
public expectations
are being met and so we can make good
livings at it but
um like i said i became very discontent
i don't want to do that this is these
are preventable diseases crooked teeth
is preventable
the world health organization has uh two
initiatives
ending childhood obesity ending
childhood tooth decay what does that
mean that means it can go away in a
generation
you ask the question that's a great
question the and i
proposed um not officially yet
but proposed ending childhood
malocclusion
if it's not as a result or a symptom of
a syndrome
these are preventable things and they
can go away
now they won't completely go away but we
can mitigate
these huge number pandemic numbers
you know of tooth decay obesity and
malocclusion
uh so that that's uh is being met with
resistance by people who are very
comfortable
um making a good living at what they
were trained to do and what's the matter
with that i
i don't shame them i just i i broke out
of it i don't know why
i'm sorry can you remind me what male
occlusion is male occlusion is just
poor alignment you know crooked teeth
james was pregnant that's
that was good you know it was crooked
teeth
poorly aligned jaws and teeth that's
smell occlusion
nice and um and i love the part where
you went into the paris underground to
get a sense of
some of the skulls and you know we had a
great talk uh
from some of those some of those guys a
while back who were
amazing enough to both fly from paris as
well as kind of
led us into their amazing world but i
wonder if you could say a little bit
more about that trip
yeah you know as a journalist i didn't
want to just phone it in and this was
right at the beginning when i had found
kevin's research and found found
marianna evans research
and i just wanted to sort of more deeply
understand it
and i had the opportunity um through
through some contacts at the long nail
foundation
to do this and i figured i might as well
do it did i learn anything
you know revolutionary as you know as
far as research goes no i didn't
but i was curious uh to see it for
myself because
i was even though the proof was all over
the place
i was still doubting it that that why
hadn't i learned this earlier
um and all you have to do if you doubt
it is just look at ancient skulls
and then look in the mirror and look at
the difference so
so you know if this is controversial i i
can't really understand that because
the proof is all over the place and
being down in the paris
uh quarries was just a way to to try to
see that uh face to face you know get a
little more intimate with the subject as
it were
right all right we have some questions
from uh
from the streams um forrest pound who
actually works with us on the stream um
he has a three-year-old that is too
young for breathing exercises or is she
um but it should should they be
considering dietary changes like you
know brown rice and things like that at
this point
kevin this is right up your alley
pediatric dentist you take this one
yeah depending on you know where she
lives
um she should establish a dental home we
call it by age one
so she's already been to a dentist uh
even if it's a specialist
depending on where they're trained they
don't know about this
i mean this is only starting to come to
light and enter
uh hopefully the curriculum of dentistry
and how they teach it
so eating hard food you know
i mean james talked about breastfeeding
and weaning
is really important those terms should
never be separated
nursing and weaning breastfeeding and
weaning onto hard unprocessed
foods so right now the question was
about food yes
chew celery carrots apples boom boom
boom
but uh at three years old that kid is
entering into what i call a geriatrics
patient
i like to get them at two and a half uh
i can start expanding a kid and helping
the jaw grow
but they're going to look at if that dad
walks into a pediatric dental office and
says look i
i think my kid might need expansion
they'll think he's crazy
because this isn't taught in school yet
it will be
uh thankfully for what you're doing this
this might help change it
that's interesting so yeah finding
things to chew on the chewiest foods the
better huh
yeah it's interesting my family always
made fun of me for
only eating raw vegetables uh because
they're from the south and
they boiled everything to death um but i
ended up with straight you know
basically straight teeth and
i never even saw a dentist just because
we didn't really have access to them
until i was
almost in college so my teeth my teeth
kind of may have benefited from that as
well
i wonder if that was it um let's see we
have
david madden from uh one of our feeds uh
who said he loved your talk and that
um he'd really love to hear more about
the the changes that take place
in the womb and what's causing that
uh it seems like you had some of your
slides that were showing that
they haven't even got a chance to chew
yet right
no no that's right and this is this is
something that just absolutely blew my
mind that
these are heritable traits so it brings
up the question is how can this be
be happening if this kid isn't you know
being trained to correct oral posture
or it doesn't have the chance to
breastfeed and this is something that
kevin and i were just talking about a
couple weeks ago
uh gestational apnea and i think that he
would be the the better person to
explain this because it does get
complicated
babies do too you know fetuses do chew
in the womb they chew amniotic fluid
yeah they develop the sucking and
swallowing on about mid just eight you
know 20 weeks 20
25 weeks and we have um
ultrasounds of kids and
they're you know you you can't do this
experiment this is not
uh you know a hypothesis that that can
be explored
but you can't go back in time and look
at a kid
on an ultrasound 500 years ago but you
can see
stillborn you know fetuses at 20 25
weeks and compare them like james showed
that slide
of you know what really a fairly typical
ultrasound looks like at 20 weeks
so we have proposed a
hypothesis at tufts university dental
school i have an orthodontic resident
that i'm mentoring there
and she is collecting proposing
you know she's going through the irb
proposal to collect
on kids that present to the orthodontic
clinic
at tufts uh say they're 12 and they have
you know jaws are too far back like mine
and
getting their ultrasounds from you know
bringing a woman's house where wherever
they were born in boston
and comparing what the jaw looked like
at 20 weeks in utero
and maybe there's an algorithm there
that we can predict uh
and this could be something to hey maybe
if
you know you should breastfeed rather
than bottle feed
uh i i'm very reluctant to talk about
breastfeeding because i'm a guy
and if there's any women that guy he's
never
done it he shouldn't be talking about
breastfeeding
so but you know there's there's research
going on and that's what james you have
really laid the foundation is that there
needs to be
research and data collected there just
isn't now
we can look at ancient fetuses and say
their jaws are forward
well something must have happened what
is it
maybe it's the way the mom's eating the
way she's
breathing gestational apnea is something
james brought up
who's heard of gestational apnea you
know it's
it's in the it's in the literature
gestational diabetes gestational
hypertension
ah-ha gestational apnea that could be
part of it we're proposing it and i
can't help
thinking that that perhaps if the mother
has difficulty breathing
if if she is not eating a fully balanced
diet that this can have a downstream
effect
to the feeder if a mother has has sleep
apnea
you know and there and and is uh
periodically hypoxic
that this could but but again how do you
test this you know
it's we can sit here all we want but
it's it's a pretty hard thing to test
there's already been an experiment that
was inadvertently done
and that's called smoking you know
pregnant women
when they smoked their babies were small
for gestational age
sometimes pre-term so in in cigarette
companies in the 40s and 50s were
advertising
a win-win the beautiful taste of winston
and a smaller baby easier to liver
to deliver no really i can show you ads
discussions but they've just shown that
they
know the long bones are smaller when a
woman can't breathe well during
like smoking but um how about the jaw
bones i mean if the long bones if the
legs are small
why wouldn't the jaws be small and
that's kind of what we're going to
explore at tufts uh
about this well it's interesting and i'm
i'm curious like i
i just want to be very clear that sorry
i think we have a little bit of delay
there
um but that i'm i'm a little bit curious
about things like chewing gum or that we
have a question from darren online
who's asking um if is there equivalent
of a chew toy to widen passageways like
are there other i know that some things
that you where you chew and you don't
swallow can actually cause stomach
problems like
chewing gum repeatedly but i'm curious
are there
are there kind of some chewing exercises
that we can do
i think there are oral pharyngeal
exercises which have been found to be
very effective
in increasing airway health expanding
airways they've been studying
these exercises for snoring and sleep
apnea
and they're they have a not a subtle uh
changes that that are occurring in the
airway and what these are
just exercises so if we're just eating
soft food all the time we're not
exercising this
this big powerful muscle called the
tongue right and so everything back here
can get flabby
but if you start doing these exercises
just like you're doing your curls or
push-ups or whatever
you can start to to influence some
fitness and to tone these areas
so there are several studies i think
four or five studies looking at just
doing these exercises
and their effect to improve your
breathing
interesting um and
um oh hold on a minute uh oh and and
anne marie from
uh from one of our streams is asking how
about how do you learn about the
breathing
techniques and where do you suggest that
she start
uh you know uh you start with this
incredible book called breath
no no no you don't need to do that you
can uh
you there there are thousands of years
of of uh of of research
into breathing how to breathe properly
and there are literally hundreds of
different books
i've found in my personal experience the
simplest things
um can be the best um try to focus on
your breath try to breathe slowly
breathe your nose all the time start
with that build that foundation and then
you can get into fancy pranayamas but
it's amazing how few people have proper
oral posture
how few people are really breathing
efficiently or in line with their
metabolic needs and so i think you
really start with the simplest steps
here
and then you can build up from there
nice and um and that actually leaves a
good next question from dan
um who is asking you know what is your
current
uh life and health situation after
learning all this and
you know starting from a path of of
doing breathing exercises and working
your way here and actually i think
in your book you talk a bit more about
how you kind of you went to your first
your first breathing class and it kind
of freaked you out
yeah it freaked me out and you know
breathing classes are a dime a dozen
here in san francisco you can throw a
whiskey bottle and not hit three or four
uh places like golden breathing classes
so my doctor actually told me to go to
breathing class because i kept getting
pneumonia year in year out i was
eating the right foods i was sleeping i
was exercising all the time i kept
getting sick i kept having respiratory
problems
and it did freak me out because i i just
started sweating
uh in in a way that that felt completely
unnatural
and so that is one of the things that
really spurred me
to research this more deeply and it took
me years and years to get my head around
it to understand exactly what happens at
the body
what happens with the brain when we
breathe in different ways
when we take conscious control of this
biological function
interesting and so and do you feel
healthier now after doing all this
well it makes you a complete neurotic
when you're writing about breathing for
a few more years don't do it people
trust trust me on this
um but after that uh the whole point of
this
is to do it in a certain way to
understand what proper breathing is so
it becomes an unconscious habit you
don't want to walk around like i did
with you know looking at an app or
looking at a notepad
you want to be able to acclimate your
body to
slightly higher levels of co2 to
acclimate your body so that it's very
comfortable
breathing through its nose all the time
and very comfortable breathing slowly
but
i you know as as an anecdote
as a subjective experience it absolutely
changed my life and the cat scans show
that
a year before and a year after doing
some just very simple things
massive uh expansion in in my airways i
haven't had a stuffed nose since then
you know that that's been my own
experience i'm not gonna say it's gonna
work for everyone but
if you look at the science behind this
stuff what happens when you do take
control of your breathing especially if
you're breathing
dysfunctionally or you're a mouth
breather it's not subtle what what
happens
and the science is very clear on all
that
nice and kevin i'm curious if
like how you know those of us with kids
and you know they do
already have crooked teeth and like now
like do you send them to a dentist can
you find dentists that are
is there a you know a catalog of
dentists that kind of are
are understanding how to broaden these
air passages and teeth
pallets yeah or how does that work right
now
um like something like this it
an orthodontist will call me pediatric
dentist will call me general dennis will
call me look
um i want to help
you know my dental hygienist kid i want
to help my own kid i
i've got patients i don't know how to do
this and
we're setting up a coaching network um
it's through the academy uh it's the
american academy
of physiological and aapmd physiological
and medical dentistry aapmd
and we formed this group called the
endeavor and it's a it's a consortium of
about
20 myofunctional therapists which are
speech pathologists and hygienists that
help kids do those chewing exercises
that james talked about
um but also orthodontist orthodontists
pediatric dentists and general dentists
who see
kids and we are coming up
with a way uh to teach dentists
well you know that didn't learn this in
school like i didn't i had to learn this
after dental school after my pediatric
residency training
and we're forming this consortium of
teaching dentists here's how you present
a case
you show me ten pictures of this
four-year-old in your practice you
describe the child's sleep and breathing
and we have definite validated risk
assessment tools
and then you send them to me or one of
the other
14 members and then we will sort it out
and we'll have a group discussion and we
will help you
um treat this kid you know from afar
and then eventually we need you to take
certain classes that are out there
that you didn't get in dental school but
that's that's where it's going and james
has done more for this movement
james is actually the only non-doctor
clinician
uh that's a member of the endeavor
collaborative
um and he's done so much to raise
awareness
and help little kids he has no idea how
many little kids you've already helped
james
well i i will say i had the i had the
easy job here because i am an objective
journalist going into a field that i
knew
zero about i spent several years in it
and talked to people
like you who have been working on this
stuff for decades and decades and
decades so
i was just putting the pieces of this
puzzle together and one thing that
kevin hasn't mentioned yet is a hundred
years ago
guess how we were treating crooked teeth
we were expanding pallets
so this is how it was 10 years old
when you expand the pallet you expand
the airway larger mouth larger airway
and and so only in the 1940s
did we start extracting and using braces
and and headgear and and in europe uh
that expansion lasted a lot longer
so that was a part of the presentation
that that got cut out
but uh but it's all out there and it's
it's all in the scientific literature
and anyone can look it up
nice uh we're going to welcome uh one of
the founding board members of long now
kevin kelly and the
editor at large and from wired welcome
kevin kelly
hello how you guys doing good hi kevin
i'm the second kevin okay yeah a couple
cats
you have dr kevin and you kevin yes
right i am not a doctor
um i i have a question i one of the the
this is for the anthropological side but
it was always my understanding that
when humanoids invented cooking
the discovery of control of fire and
cooking which
acted as a kind of a secondary outside
stomach that allowed us to
digest nutrition that we could not do
easily
that that actually changed our jaws and
our teeth
in on the historical you know i don't
know whether it's million years or
certainly hundreds of thousands of years
and so i'm wondering if if what we're
seeing now is kind of continuation of
that longer story
uh that's exactly what happened though
800 000 years ago
um i think that's one of the earliest uh
discoveries of of the use of controlled
fire
and so having all of this extra energy
available that we save from from chewing
that was released in cooking allowed us
to grow a larger brain
and that brain needed space so it took
that space
from the front of the face and our faces
started growing
flatter okay and our teeth start getting
smaller and our jaws start getting
smaller but these changes happened over
tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of years and we
acclimated to these changes
just fine so according to the skeletal
record we were breathing just fine
so uh what has happened to modern humans
in the past
few hundred years this happens so quick
we have not been able to cat
right so our mouths are way too small
our teeth are
okay our ways are but but the the
general trend though is a continuation
of that trend right of reducing the size
of the jaws and the teeth so you could
kind of say that it's sort of like
a continuation of that same process
of modernization and eating
cooked food that's like saying obesity
is a continuation and we're just going
to keep getting fatter
and you know i i know exactly what you
meant there
but no we have to stop this trend i i
mean
narrowing jaws and obesity there there
one is um over abundance and too big and
the other one
is too small and under um
you know uh achievement if you will it's
just
no it's a trend that has to stop but
yeah if it continues
it's it's disaster so um if you take the
kind of again the long view and this
time going
not the long past but the long future if
you imagine
uh some scenarios for the next hundred
years
um what would our jaws
look like in a hundred years do we
imagine
that they would be the same size they
were
in the last couple thousand years would
we like to
have we identified any genes of our jaw
size and teeth that we might want to
engineer
to make larger or i mean like if we
could imagine us taking control of this
what would you imagine we might do you
could have more than one scenario but
what would be some of the things
we might do in 100 years regarding our
draws and tee size
yeah you know go back to to eating whole
foods
is is the first thing that that you
should do i mean we want to live up to
our epigenetic potential
right we don't want our mouths to
continue growing smaller and smaller and
smaller and their teeth to be
getting more and more crooked so jeans
can be turned on they can be turned off
so if we see this dis evolution
happening right now if we've taken a
sharp
left turn if our airways have taken a
sharp left turn we can work to help
restore that i've found even if you're
in middle age you can show improvement
to your palate you can show improvement
to your airway so
uh the the body is plastic i was just
talking to someone about
i think we should be talking about
breathing plasticity or mouth plasticity
uh the human body can be changed for the
better or for the worse depending on
what environment
environmental inputs are given to it
and so kevin do you have an idea of what
might happen over 100 years
ago what some of the possibilities would
be the the genes
you know there there isn't a gene that
or as a suite of genes you know there's
no there's just not one gene one trait
it doesn't work that way very seldom
there are a few things like that
is that there's groups of genes on
individual chromosomes that interact
with genes on other chromosomes
in concert interacting with the
environment it's epigenetics
so you can have a group of genes
that will code for type 2 diabetes that
never expresses itself
if the person lives a healthy lifestyle
you can you can carry those genes but
they just won't turn on unless you
subject it
to an environment and it's the same
thing with malocclusion
so in the next hundred years you know
people are gonna wake up i mean you know
james
james has an acumen for anthropology and
natural selection
that rivals like hugely rivals
most health care professionals we don't
have to learn about how natural
selection works
when we're in medical and dental school
you know we deal with proximate cause
you got a fever take an aspirin
um well maybe we should find out what
pathogen is causing
causing the fever and james has really
grasped
such an understanding and appreciation
of how important it is
to understand the evolutionary
explanation
rather than the proximate cause of
disease so
getting to your question like well is it
a linear projection in a hundred years
like if the jaws have gotten this small
a hundred years what's it gonna be
a hundred years from now and is it it
won't be linear i
i think if it were that it would
contribute to human extinction
and and i just don't think people like
to think that humans can go extinct
a lot of that is religious but we can
like every other species on earth 99.9
of everything that's ever been born from
the first bacteria
4 billion years ago everything's extinct
except a few things that are here now
and that's where we're headed if we
don't get a you know this and other
things
breathing properly through the nose and
having jaws that are conducive to that
and taking in adequate nutrition we're
smart we have a big frontal cortex
lucky for us we better start using it
nice well we're going to wrap this up
and i'd love to thank actually both
kevin's
dr kevin boyd and kevin kelly um and
actually and
we'll uh we'll just go to james and i as
we i give
the last couple questions um
thank you guys um james i'm
i think uh kev dr kevin boyd did a great
job of pointing out how
bad i think um many times when people
are
siloed in their professions they're
really bad at kind of connecting the
dots and
and we've seen you know over and over
again with some of our like all species
initiatives and the language initiatives
that
uh it's rare that people can you know
they they actually kind of get
uh academia really rewards
specialization
and doesn't really reward generalization
and so the work that you've done here
and kind of
helping these people kind of connect
with each other i suspect you even
in your research you help them find each
other uh to some extent
uh in what they're doing so i think it's
it's it was a great effort
and um and so cool to see and so i'm
really curious as to what your next
project is
i have another book idea but the idea of
uh you know sitting in a
in a room for three years and riding
alone uh just kind of makes me queasy
so i'm gonna just uh continue talking
about uh breathing for a little while
longer i'm still excited
about the subject every time i talk to
kevin i get all amped up
and i want to get this word out but
hopefully we're going to bring
um this and and some of the other
subjects i've talked about at long now
uh into a different medium
uh perhaps into a a video
kind of series and so um i'm looking
into that but
you know in about a year i think i'll be
it'll be time for
to sink back into a new project
well we're all stuck in rooms in front
of our computer screens now so
we're all writers now but uh yeah i
think
we've all got beards now everybody yeah
there it is nice well i want to thank
you for everybody i do want to say like
that
that you did a great job of kind of
going down a much more long now angle of
what your book is and there's so many
more great stories in your book and i
really want to encourage people to read
it it reads really well and i was i've
been listening to it
uh or i listened i ended up listening to
all of it and you do a great job reading
your book so it's great to hear your
voice
in the audio version which i i enjoyed
so thank you so much for joining us
and thank you all for joining the live
stream and look forward to
um i think we're coming up on our last
event of the year we'll be next will be
lost landscapes um which will not be one
of our normal events but uh we'll be
back on in january
and hopefully on the other side of 2020.
thank you all thank you
[Music]
you